so a war broke out uh it was expected to
last for a week or two but it lasted for
nearly 3 years and the scale of that war
was so massive that close to 1.5 million
people died it was a terrible thing um
so so you know I I and and it affected
my family very well I have an uncle who
nobody was is unaccounted for he never
came back you know he joined the the
befan soldiers um my dad was only a week
or two from joining he was only 15 you
know when the war ended so so but I've
I've decided to write about it for a
long time you know it's the one book
I've always wanted to write uh but again
how do you tell the story in a new way
in a fresh
way and uh I found it uh again going
back to my mom who hates to talk about
the war just like every other person
witnessed you know aspects of it and I
asked him like you know what whether you
like it or not I'm going to write this
novel about the bean war and she was
like okay if you want to do that go
ahead but remember something uh those
who often tell the story of a thing like
a war like you know of conflict are
usually Del
leaveing but what is the purpose of War
it's basically to kill so the product of
war is death but the dead never speak
about it because they
can't so she's like this is why I don't
like to talk about it so if you are
going to write a novel about a war then
make sure that all voices are heard and
I was like oh my goodness that is it so
the the basic premise of the novel The
Road to the country uh is that the story
is told by both the living and the
dead oh goodness see that's uh see you
you while you disagree with my point
about the nature of poetry and War you
just made it no I don't I don't disagree
but that's not what I'm doing no but you
did because it's just like this uh
you've taken something you've seen yes
you know poetry is interesting I I'm no
poet and I'm no scholar of poetry I just
have all these around around me and they
teach me
it always starts with particulars yes
something you see but then the
imagination of the poet turns it
into yeah a truth yes a an abstract
abiding universal truth so what you've
done is in Orchestra of minorities and
in this new book uh you've brought the
dead back to life they get to tell their
story yeah that's amazing so
and I have uh in admiration and
friendship I have adjured you to give it
a happy
ending I'll
try and you haven't quite made a
commitment I noticed and you didn't
quite there either but I repeat my
adoration people need to be happy once
in a while I would try it uh I promise
you I I would I would change the ending
because of you see that time don't
believe it for a minute it's uh so uh I
want to explore a little bit because um
what's interesting to me is you open up
an entirely different culture to us to
we Americans and to we in the west and
you're part of
both and uh that's valuable I think I'm
going to India in a few days and you've
encourage me to go and it's I've been
learning about it and it's a different
world and I'm galvanized by the prospect
of going MH on the other
hand
uh these books you write are popular in
America and in the west and that must
mean they speak of something that's
common to us all could you talk about
that a little bit Yeah indeed
uh it's I think I think there's a
mysterious aspect to it but
um what one does even though they there
are these Grand
ideas obviously that that one is trying
to tackle cosmology War uh and all of
that but you know my story I believe
that fiction is really about
relationships um and in fact connections
and disconnections you know when I I
teach my course uh creative writing
course here I it's I I tell the students
that um it's it's a lot of things but at
the at the granular level it's it's that
um so you begin with that uh I I often
tell them my students that there are two
types of
fiction at least process of writing
fiction one is uh a work of fiction
where
plot is a function of character and one
where is the reverse character is a
function of plot I prefer the the the
former uh because um
I think that plot usually is
inconsequential when you're starting you
think about people uh you you you know
there a guy whom I know uh whom his name
is uh Rafael something can't remember
his saw name but it makes the the point
that the the the first instantiation of
an idea in in the in any work of
literature is actually place and
character so if you if you think about a
guy like MCB he exist only within the
universe that Shakespeare has placed him
if you ex you know if you export marbet
out of that setting and put him in
Hillsdale City it's going to change him
it's not going to be the same character
you know so even a a slight modulation
of of tone of atmosphere changes the
character of of the character and of the
story uh so I begin from character so
you think you you come up with a person
you think to yourself uh what is
interesting about this guy uh who is in
love who has gone to Cyprus sold
everything he has because of the love he
has for this woman or about this this
this boy who has been given this
prophecy that one of his brothers will
kill him and he's become insane because
of that so these are people so I I start
to think about them sleep with this
people in my mind and then you send the
characters into the world you know you
imbue them with the qualities that you
want them to have and plot images
organically from that it's like setting
something into motion and just let it go
and you know so I don't really worry
about plot it emerges organically once
you have uh a
perfect image of character so uh you
know I I think I may have gone on a
tangent but but I I hope I'm answering
your question very yes if so uh let me
first of all imagine MC Beth in
hillst it's getting dark here early I'm
walking home there're these three
witches yes they have out of nowhere
they uh tell me that I could be the
ruler of the universe and the next thing
you know I kill somebody and then I get
killed by McDuff yeah except since I
know the plot I might not react that
way it's a all one in yeah I mean that's
so here's the thing I mean in in the
orchestra minorities in
mcbath for a time in both of those works
of fiction the protagonist is a wholly
worthy
character and so you've you subject them
to things
and Shakespeare does that show something
else in them what you're saying is it's
not the plot that makes them it's the
plot that reveals them exactly and that
means you saw that in them in your mind
as Shakespeare did yes and and and that
re so I you know I love that word I I I
I remember there a an interview I gave
some in some newspaper sometime that
came out as the title fiction is re as
Revelation something like that so yes
it's it's indeed Revelation you know and
and I'm surprised by what I see when
when what is revealed to me once I have
Tau up those characters uh and I and I
think to go back to your question about
universality that is what people connect
with uh you know there's a and the
fishermen um you know so so the
mysterious part is uh how you know the
for instance in its first year sold more
copies in
Sweden than in the US yeah where I live
uh and you know uh sold 50,000 copies in
China and and and and then you you you
think about you know the fact that these
are characters who live in a small town
not even Lagos an unknown place in
Nigeria in the 90s there's no connection
to Chinese culture in any way but but
that's that's what they're connecting to
really it is the fact that everybody
even if you don't have a sibling you
understand what it
means you know to have one you know you
that that sibling bond that that the the
the boys share is is is in some ways
Universal so but how how one um and
there there's something and that takes
us back to the Revelation there's
something that is revealed to them
through the connection through the
relationships you know that the brothers
have or that Chino has with his uh you
know with his girlfriend in in an
orchestal minorities that moves people
and and you know so I just I just create
this uh this character and these uh
situations and and then the reader takes
it from there I
think